[Musique]
cette nuit à l'aéroport international de
Katmandou cet homme rentre seul du Qatar
avec le cercle de son collègue et ami
tous les deux travaillaient en tant
qu'ouvrier sur les chantiers de la Coupe
du monde
ou Messi Adam avait 35 ans il est mort
en tombant d'un échafaudage il
travaillait sur un immeuble en
construction on travaillait pour la même
société on n'était pas ensemble lorsque
l'accident s'est produit c'est pour
soutenir sa famille du mieux que je peux
que j'accompagne son corps au Népal il a
une femme des enfants des parents un
petit frère l'ami du défunt préfère
rester anonyme il retournera sur ce dans
une semaine des ouvriers n'est pas les
parties gagnées un peu d'argent au Qatar
dont ne revienne que des cercueils il y
en a eu des milliers depuis
l'attribution du Mondial à les Mira en
2010 malgré tous les candidats sont
toujours aussi nombreux
passeport en main 500 n'est pas les par
jour tant d'obtenir un visa pour le
Qatar parmi eux sourate 31 ans se perd
de famille espère gagner 300 euros par
mois pour un poste de bagagiste ces
trois fois le salaire moyen au Népal
c'est notre responsabilité de prendre ce
type d'emploi j'ai 9 membres de ma
famille à nourrir les ouvriers n'est pas
les représentent la principale main
d'oeuvre étrangère sur les chantiers de
la Coupe du monde
la plupart viennent de s'écouler nos
pieds de l'Himalaya à l'extrême ouest du
Népal une région très agricole pour
s'extirper de la pauvreté et la majorité
des hommes quittent le pays au risque de
ne pas revenir et de laisser leur
famille dans une détresse encore plus
grande
comme Siri taille ses enfants
il y a six mois son mari est mort adoa
sur le chantier de l'un des stades en
construction il avait 31 ans
[Applaudissements]
cela faisait trois ans qu'il travaillait
là-bas le couple rêvait d'un avenir
meilleur pour leur fille et leur fils
travailler au Qatar pour qu'on
construise notre maison là-bas ils sont
contents ils ont ce qu'ils veulent ils
vont être heureux en jouant leur coupe
du monde mais tous bonheur nous a été
enlevés ils ont la gloire et nous on a
rien
juste un papier disant que mon mari est
mort d'une crise cardiaque à chaque fois
qu'un travailleur n'est pas les meurs au
Qatar la cause est presque toujours la
même une crise cardiaque une mort
naturelle qui ne permet pas aux familles
de recevoir une compensation de
l'employeur un tel taux de mortalité
pour une population
âgée de 20 à 40 ans et plus qu'alarmant
selon ce médecin
le gouvernement n'est pas laine autorise
plus les travailleurs à partir à
l'étranger sans passer un bilan de santé
complet les crises cardiaques touchent
principalement les personnes âgées de 50
ans et plus or ceux qui partent à
l'étranger sont principalement des
jeunes c'est une véritable préoccupation
le gouvernement n'est parlé devrait se
pencher sur la question
difficile de connaître le nombre exact
de morts selon le gouvernement népalais
13000 de ces ressortissants auraient
travaillé sur les différents chantiers
de la Coupe du Monde hôtel aéroport root
et bien sûr dans les stades parmi eux
toujours selon le gouvernement près de
2000 n'est pas vous aurez décédé un
chiffre au très largement sous-estimé
aux yeux des différentes ONG
assimilée de vie perdus s'ajoutent
autant de vie brisées
sousraient à travailler 15 longues
années dans ce petit pays du Golfe
il était maçon sur le chantier du stade
où ce jour à la finale du Mondial
à 43 ans il souffre de dysfonctionnement
ou de reins voici les médicaments que je
prends chaque jour il y en a ici là et
là je prends aussi des injections
d'insuline rien que pour ce médicament
je dois valer sept comprimés par jour
à 42 ans 42 ans c'est jeune non
alors oui je suis vivant mais déjà morte
pour survivre il a dure recevoir le rein
de sa mère donneuse compatible tout ce
qu'il a gagné au Qatar il l'a dépensé
pour ce soigner
j'ai tout dépensé tout dépenser pas en
tout près de 20.000 euros pour lui aucun
doute ces conditions de vie et de
travail lui ont causé ces séquelles
irréversibles on travaille de 4 heures
du matin à 21h il fait chaud comme
l'enfer parfois il n'y a pas de
climatisation même pas dans les engins
après une journée de travail fatigante
on regagne nos chambres bondées pour les
toilettes sur certains chantiers sans
personne font la queue sur un seul WC
en fait vous êtes leur esclave n'est ce
pas
accompagné de sa femme l'ancien ouvrier
rend visite à une association d'avocats
qui défend les droits des travailleurs
migrants gratuitement
et les aides à obtenir des
indemnisations depuis 2011 l'ONG a
défendu plus de 28 000 plaintes de
travailleurs népalais revenant du Qatar
et des autres pays du Golfe cela ne
devrait pas prendre plus de 7 à 8 mois
maximum pour traiter votre demande
ton dossier est accepté il pourrait
recevoir un peu plus de 5000 euros de la
part du gouvernement népalais un
gouvernement qui accepte d'alouer des
compensations tout en fermant les yeux
sur les agissements catharis car la
diaspora n'est pas l'aise rapporte un
tiers du PIB au pays de son côté les
Mira refusent de créer un fond
d'indemnisation pour les ouvriers
nous retrouvons sous radep le jeune père
de famille prêt à s'envoler pour Doha en
attendant son visa il séjourne dans ce
petit hôtel avec deux amis de son
village tous les trois devront rester au
moins deux ans au Qatar sans revenir ce
sont les conditions du
contrats je vais travailler gagner de
l'argent
et je reviendrai avec un sac-plan
un destin qu'ils acceptent résignés pour
leurs enfants
une bonne éducation tu vas pouvoir
améliorer notre pays changer les lois
crée des emplois pour les gens comme
nous
et peut-être qu'on aura plus besoin
d'aller dans d'autres pays
c'est mon seul rêve
au Qatar les touristes remplacent peu à
peu les ouvriers étrangers
désormais les Népalais s'envoles
principalement vers l’arabie Saoudite
qui accueillera les Jeux asiatiques
d'hiver en 2029